let me start by saying congratulations
you did not crash the Ferrari all right
good to hear you know what I mean
um so uh we're here to talk about across
the spider-verse but I know you guys are
knee-deep in beyond the spider verse so
um I just have to ask you for fans who
are going to see this and be like oh my
God there's another one where are you in
the production process of that we are in
the process of being so thankful that we
survived making this one that's where
we're at uh no I mean good answer yeah
that's really the best answer I think
for that I mean obviously when we
conceptualized it we broke the story for
for both of these films but obviously
this came down to the wire and I think
you know the the immediate priorities to
get a little bit of a break for for
folks but um but know that very much
this is part two of a three-part series
that was decided before this was even
made and there will be a third part
that's pretty much all we can really say
totally cool yeah so this movie's about
two hours 20 minutes and I'm just
curious did at any point the studio say
um we would rather have it closer to two
hours like how did you guys decide on
you know like being able to tell a story
in a longer format well I mean it's um
obviously you're always going to get you
know encouraged to trim and tighten and
and make it as as tight as humanly
possible which we no one wants to do
that more than us but but at the end of
the day it's um
is is the audience engaged and I think
what what really settled us on we don't
think that there's any fat in this film
to be honest and when you start
screening it for a test audience and you
we started screening it for test
audiences and we figured out the final
things that we cut and we finally
screened a version that audience not
only enjoyed but
it they didn't feel like it was was
running too long so I mean we remind
people that this is meant to be a film
it's uh animation is a medium that we
work in but we treat it like like any um
other film that any of us would be
making and um again it's we there's a
story we're trying to tell and we need
to make sure we give ourselves enough
time to tell it hopefully people will be
engaged enough that time is not an issue
that they think about during that first
of all this movie could have been three
hours and I would have been sitting
there and taking it all in but you know
there's that element of you know and I
think a lot of audiences don't associate
animation with um the first into the
spider-verse was almost two hours long
yeah which at a time when people were
like animated films are supposed to be
80 85 88 minutes and they came out with
the first one and it was almost two
hours and no one really noticed so I
think that kind of established the
template and that you take the time you
need to take to tell the story that you
need to take I think I think that's it
let me just say like the first movie uh
was
you know so groundbreaking storytelling
wise and and and Visually and it took uh
it took you on this journey with this
this kid Miles Morales who we fell in
love with and he was at an early part of
his development as he was a as a spider
person as a hero
um but he was a kid and he was 13. we
were meeting him in this film a year and
a half later
and he's 15 years old he's dealing with
much more complex problems you know and
the complexity to do that Justice we
needed time to tell that story and we
wanted to set up the the right
um the right pacing for that so we could
have enough time for our lows and our
highs in this film and without those
lows without those really strong
emotional beats none of the crashing and
bashing none of the none of the the the
spectacular visuals and stuff that we
set out to to to to to make in this
movie would really matter so for us
I don't think lengths was really much of
like our primary concern at all what was
our primary concern is did we care about
what was going on did we actually want
miles to succeed yeah did we actually
feel that tug of
Rio and Miles like Rio is heartbreaking
as she says goodbye to Miles and and and
gives him permission to leave the nest
essentially you know as parents we're
all parents and and I think the heart of
this emotional story as parents we've
we've all been in those places with our
own children where you are you're you're
trying to hold on to them and you have
to let them grow up and it's the most
painful thing that I've ever been
through and trying to keep letting those
moments play themselves out naturally
versus fit into like you know whatever
our running time is I think that that's
what you want you want to you want the
the naturalism to really shine through
on those listen we're on the same page
the character moments are what everyone
loves about these movies it's not the
way Spider-Man fights in a scene yeah
it's the it's the characters so it's
very unusual to have three directors on
a project and I'm just curious did you
guys sort of have your own specialty in
the direct acting to make sure this
product you know what I mean like or
like could you sort of take me through
like how there's three directors on this
sure well I mean I think the first one
set the pace there was three directors
on the first one it's a big film this is
a bigger film
um yeah we all do have our Specialties
so you know I started in the industry as
a story artist
um so a lot of my storytelling skill is
through visuals it's through camera work
it's through compositions uh and taking
what's written and translating that and
disseminating that to a crew uh that's
gonna that's gonna get
an add to uh what the script is already
doing so well
oh I mean you're if we're going taking
turns I mean I'll just say like you know
I was a production designer on the first
film I've been you know obviously that's
my background but but ultimately I think
the three of us we all bring our unique
experiences this movie is too big
honestly it is like making five movies
at once right there's no way we could
possibly be in every place we need to be
logistically speaking and make this
movie as if there was just one director
um and then I think also the
the level of expectation not just based
on the first film but the fans
themselves the the fans of Spider-Man
own that character that character is so
beloved and needs so much
brought to the screen to bring it to
life in the right way yeah that it does
take three Brilliant Minds like ours to
to act self to actually
um to actually make it to make it all
come together in the way that it needed
to so I mean yeah obviously my visual my
my background as a visual designer and a
production designer obviously it's going
to influence have a direct influence on
our ability to take story and translate
that those internal ideas into something
external
yeah I mean obviously
with my background
um it's combinated been a combination
things I love working with the actors so
actually directing the vocal
performances was something that I really
took of you know a lot of joy in
spending a lot of time in edit
um and cutting it all together I mean
the way it worked functionally was in
the beginning
it was all of us doing everything yeah
so every single meeting we were all
three of us kind of coming to a quorum
in the meeting then you get to a certain
point in the production and we kind of
split up into three silos
yes for us to all kind of get on the
same page and we can work with all the
ideas yeah together and it was like we I
think we all wanted to make the same
movie exactly exactly and then we kind
of split up into our specialty silos to
execute those ideas so that's me going
off and doing recording sessions with
the cast and then sitting and edit with
Mike Andrews and Phil and kind of
cutting it together you know just in
going more into the visuals walking you
know it just you know we can
conceptualize worked on it together and
then kind of split up in order to
actually execute it and then every make
sure we checked in so every week it's
like you get to see what the other
person's doing and give your notes and
give your input on that and that's
really I mean it's kind of a miracle
that we got the movie done considering
how much we had to really tackle in such
a short period of time so my my question
is because you knew that this was a
two-part movie when you were doing vocal
recording with the actors or you're
working on this whole thing were you
working on both parts of this same time
or is it one of these things where so
like all the vocal stuff's done for both
movies no you know some of it is yeah we
have some vocal stuff done for the
second film but no not all of it's done
for both movies they're all going to be
coming back and look yeah these things
they evolve over time you're not you
don't it's not exactly to the letter of
the law with what's on the script with
what ends up on screen it evolves so
that'll that'll continue to happen
through the next film as well you know
changes will come at the last minute
you'll screen it and you'll get
reactions right that'll cause you to
Pivot and honestly people's reactions to
this film is going to influence an
impact what happens with that next film
so so behind you we can see some of the
spider characters there is a few scenes
in this movie where there are an ungodly
amount of spider characters do you
actually know how many spider people if
you will are in the movie like the final
number the exact number boy because we
kept adding
like all the way up until the very end
and I don't think I've honestly I'm
gonna be a level with you I we just
finished the film like in the last like
two weeks and and I don't think I've had
time to pause and actually take a final
count but I think I was about 280 the
last time I looked in but that doesn't
necessarily mean just to be clear that
doesn't mean
um like specific unique characters that
you might recognize it might mean
variations as well but if you're just
talking about named characters then I
think there's probably about 95. the
animators like when I was watching this
movie I wanted to push pause about a
thousand times and I will do that when
it's eventually on home video but one of
the things is has have any of you
actually pushed pause on every frame
because I would imagine some of the
animators are going to sneak through
some things maybe that you know I'm sure
it's happened on some yeah but I will
say this we had a different experience
we've talked about this a little a
little earlier yeah we came into
screening rooms assuming that we were
looking at like key art or paintings and
we sat down we're like this Dev looks
great and then they hit play and it
started moving we were like what is
happening right now you know it sort of
shifted our entire sort of Paradigm
um so yeah I mean I think that's going
to be one of the the treats of this film
is that you'll want to go back and watch
it again and again because there is I
mean there is so much to discover yeah
no matter how many times we pause you
can't catch roll I think we actually
have been in the past week just now
taking stock of the Easter eggs that's
right I think yeah this week has like
been the first time people are actually
in a room going through every single
Easter egg so to figure out everything
that's actually I tell you that your
final in the film yeah and it's funny I
think part of it yeah yeah and I think
part of the reason why like why is
because
there all these different departments
are working at the same time and each
department is getting their own Easter
eggs in yes and so a lot of it is is you
know for example one of my favorite
Easter eggs to track is how many times
our head of character animation Alan
Hawkins makes an appearance in the film
there's no money he's on 80s he's on
money like he's like he his his
animation crew like love their love for
him and just using him as a gag in the
background and there's actually a little
Story Journey that they created for Alan
Hawkins he became everybody's icon at
some point everybody logged on to one of
the sessions and then was just different
faces
and so there's like actually this whole
like Journey that I expect to see fully
like developed on the internet at some
point just tracking Ellen through the
movie this is a male already looking
forward to
um what day of the production did
someone want to rage quit when you said
we're gonna anime take this and now
we're going to add water and Rain no not
at all I'm joking I'm joking around
actually I think you couldn't get me to
rage quit this movie if you tried and in
fact many people might have expected me
to many times but I think that the idea
of like
being given an opportunity to work on
the world's most expensive independent
Art House film is is probably like a
dream come true as an artist and being
able to express ourselves as fully with
a crew of almost a thousand people
working for 700 and what is amounts to
735 years of of work
um yeah quite literally
um
and how dedicated and committed they
were to that this this just
experimenting and doing something new at
all times
you couldn't pull me away from that
while also like like under uh sorry for
the sound guys
um but while also all of that being
supported by this by the gravitas and
the weight of this incredible emotional
Journey you couldn't pull me away from
that yeah it was more like an animator
who's like are you because you keep
you're pushing the technology you know
what I mean hard to deliver this film we
I mean we were joking you know one of
the there's small things that you don't
take into account uh that maybe didn't
happen on the first film that happened
on this one Gwen putting her hair up in
a bun that's a that's an expensive
decision like you gotta you gotta lean
in and go like yeah no it's what's
what's right for the character is what's
right for the moment it'll add
naturalism and then you got people that
are literally going like that's gonna
cost us this amount of money
uh so yeah removing a mask pulling off a
mask is one of the big slowly so that
you see it tugging on the skin that's a
big gesture and an animation is the
spider people pulling their masks off
well it says your specific point though
I see what you're asking like I actually
know our crew didn't want to leave the
movie actually I I mean I literally got
a letter from them a couple days ago
how much they wish they could keep
working on this because it was so
inspiring to them that almost moved me
to tears to read because we did ask so
much of them but they were so committed
the whole time
these movies having worked on the first
movie as a production designer and now
as a director on this with these guys
like these movies like are an
opportunity you rarely get anywhere in
your career like to do something where
people where we give people permission
we're given permission to ourselves and
the support of the studio behind that to
experiment and to do things nobody's
tried before
it you don't realize like the crew like
made this movie like they are they own
this movie as much as any of us yeah
we're lucky we get to be up here and do
the thing yeah but it's it's their
passion
um and also just from the first few
frames when you see logos and it's
already doing cool stuff I'm like oh my
God I was so happy you know just because
it pulls you right you're giving it
through the Sony logo without going like
oh wow look at it right I definitely
have to ask you because I'm running out
of time about music because the first
film soundtrack is people love it and
I'm just curious what it was like with
the sequel sequels figuring out what
songs you want to put in because I would
imagine there's a lot of artists who are
like I want to be in this movie yeah it
was a two-part well the bigger challenge
is what we're going to use Music versus
score because we have we're uh you know
just a wealth so many riches and that we
have Daniel Pemberton who came back for
the score as well as Metro Boomin who
was executive producing the soundtrack
and then a few needle drop songs of our
own choices to throw in there so you
know for for a lot of the production of
the film we're using tent music and
we're deciding throughout the process
what works better in this moment temp or
score temp or score and you know know
Metro being probably one of the most
amazing producers in the world today
he's the one who went out and found the
artist that he wanted to bring on to a
lot of these tracks and what I love
about what Metro does is that you know
he he speaks to like the past the
present and like what's coming in the
future and I think that's reflected you
know I was you know James Blake is one
of my favorite artists and you know to
hear a James Blake song Metro song is
like amazing to me but it's like we also
get rock Kim in there and then Daniel
Pemberton does some things with a score
he had already done such an amazing
score with the first film but he did
such an amazing Evolution I think of the
score that from the opening those
opening credits you talk about where
like the logos are coming up and the
score just says to you like okay this is
something different you know and and
it's a lot of it was trial and error to
be honest
um that's the wonderful thing about
animation it's an iterative process so
we we got to drop in different kinds of
music and different moments of the film
and see what was the most effective what
you know have most impact emotionally on
the audience and it's an equalizing
thing you do until the the very end